Lisey’s Story is a story
of a woman’s courage.
It’s about a woman who
is trying to find herself
again after the loss
of her husband.
It’s a relatable story of
family and marriage,
and then it goes to a place
that only a wild imagination
like Stephen King’s could take you.
It’s a very scary
story in a lot of ways.
It’s scary in a supernatural way
but it’s also scary because
there really are dangerous
people out there.
This is a story about
love and relationships
and how we save each other.
It’s so multi-layered, you know.
It’s terribly romantic.
It’s terrifying at times.
And it’s upsetting and it’s
full of pain and beauty.
Lisey is completely grief stricken.
I’ve left Lisey a bool hunt.
I’ve given her clues that she
is diving into with her grief.
Nobody really knows what
goes on in a marriage
except the two people who are in it.
What is that world that only
the two of them know about?
Lisey is kind of drawn into this world.
Lisey is trying to save her
sister and save her husband
and then there’s this kind
of outside pressure where
someone is menacing her all the time.
When Scott dies, my character wants
his unpublished works to be published.
He thinks Lisey is holding
them away from the public,
so he makes it his mission
and he’ll do pretty much
anything to make sure that happens.
Secrets secrets are no fun.
Secrets secrets hurt someone.
We are straddling whole
different worlds and in
some ways whole different genres.
I think that in and of
itself is really unusual,
to have this kind of horror,
this supernatural element.
Where'd you go?
Come back.
It’s very unique and unusual,
a really strong, beautiful vision.
It just works on so many levels.
Stephen King has crafted
this beautiful story.
He’s someone who’s
been able to understand
our humanity in
a very universal way.
This is a love story.
It’s a beautiful, unearthly thing.